[Music]
everyday we're going to talk about
Rafael Nadal at the US Open we're gonna
talk about Joe Jonas making out with
Sansa Stark but first watch this this
happened at the u.s. element is a
chicken finger into a soda pop and
eating it watch or is this a bad idea I
think this is gonna be the next lace
chip flavor so you're into it
is anyone anti I'm anti your anthem why
bad it bad cuz chicken wet now wow the
internet agrees with Natasha they got
furious over this the poor woman's head
she's receiving death threats said that
she should go to jail I want us to try
it right now
oh yeah actually how some chicken favor
is this why is death threat the first
thing people go for yeah jeez they're
already a little soggy 1e pretty good
was great I don't want anyone's young
but this is really gross you guys your
taste buds just a lazy thing like nugget
did sip the coke you don't do it all
sauce options at the US Open so she's
probably just no no she's like a
competitive eater
you can't just dip everything because
you want to eat it
and we have some napkins it's like you
don't like we're back in your drink
sometimes it's like yeah you drink
separately I'd patience male yes
everyone put down their chicken the blue
team does not support this I want to
talk about Rafael Nadal now he had one
of the most epic games of all time it
went four hours and 48 minutes he made
it to the semi as he beat Dominick team
pull up that headline Julian this brings
me to the question is tennis the best
sport of all time anyone thinks it is
know why yes Joe clearly is if you just
watch some of this match these guys are
enduring like pure hell this is all is
this human emotion on the table they're
battling each other they're battling
them set on the court on the table while
make an argument for what the best board
of all time is really undercut your
authority listen you're battling each
other you're battling your cells mostly
that's that's really tough as you pull
up that next headline yes also tennis
you live longer than any other sport any
other if you play another sport then
you'll live less longer than if you
played tennis do yoga you'll live so
long or eat bacon or all this horseshit
who cares
I'm with Jordan I love tennis you would
sit there for five hours to watch one
man yeah dude it's a fine sport but it's
not the best sport it's inaccessible I
don't know what yeah all you need is a
racquet and there's frequently you know
in a abacus to keep score cuz so now
it's four
it goes from 40 to a word what I got so
it's confusing it's for rich people
that's right it's for rich people other
sports don't have words and numbers the
scoring is confusing I'm not saying it's
a bad sport it's a confusing sport and
also it's not gonna be you you're not
gonna convince me that's fun when you're
not allowed to make noise for most of
the game and then they tell you you can
clap for two seconds and then I'm gonna
scream it some other guy's gonna scream
I'm a phony bass so they can hit it back
and forth again they shush people if I
use the entire time that you were
speaking right there which I wanted to
do knowing and distract actually I would
have liked a baseball you don't have to
even be like fit to play baseball talk
about five hours baseball it takes like
12 years baseball is like see a family
and your blue team you have to agree
what I agreed so bad but it's what's
your points where now my name is great
to watch it's not good and it's not as
good as other spikes is jump to the word
love the word love is just love that's
great I love Ryan say that's a camera
are you anti loud we know what I have to
say to explain that I like tennis just
fine I don't think you heard it here
Ryan back hates pot and he's gonna take
this next story Joe Jonas and Kevin
Jonas are at the US Open and they're
having a fun time they're drinking beer
they're swelling they know the cameras
on them and they're having a fun time
and just when you think they couldn't
have any more fun they start doing the
backpack dance and show that next photo
Gillian Oh baby that's honest
oh they're smooching you're telling me
tennis is no that's how boring tennis is
this is a headline this is the
distraction drinks beer and kiss at
every sporting event it's a fine sport
not the best and also they definitely
didn't do this while the match was going
because some guy with a megaphone would
be like knock that off you Rascals
I'm saying they were there kissing a
very loudly is PDA okay is this sort of
thing okay in general yeah this seemed
like a kiss-cam thing so I'm like fine
with this there's like these people just
going at it on the train and I was
watching them but they were making out
hard like oh my gosh we don't have any
time but now you know in the end that's
too much I think if you planning on
doing it you're awful but if when you
land a PDA and people are weird
people are weird appoint someone it's
like you know I'm gonna go to this
baseball game and get handsy with her oh
yeah oh yeah there's there's some creepy
people out there and lo if it's happenin
and everybody's all in make it happen it
was a humid night I don't share it all I
don't think Chris agrees with anything
he's saying he said let me just uh oh
I'm talking
[Laughter]
and now my hands are moving one night in
the US Open is tennis the most fun sport
to watch yes or no rapid fire Chris no
yes no yes yes is-3 knows and in tennis
rules that means tennis wins you guys
shout out for us yes let's see Smith
says who's up for the hashtag Nicki
Minaj sex challenge which is a sex
challenge that I coined yesterday the
sec challenge is that you have to have
sex three times in a night you have an
hour and a half in between to have sex
but in between you also have to eat a
whole sandwich so if you guys there's 25
people who liked his comment if any of
you want to do the sex challenge and
send us a video we will show it in its
entirety on the show asking for videos
of people voting okay well sound off in
the comments if you think it's time's up
for Jordan Mendoza this is Ben every
damn day
[Music]
never call anyone it's rude and never
answer the phone it's disgusting
[Music]
yes she's all that as a movie about
accepting others for who they are but
isn't it also a movie about how artists
can't be pretty you try it out for your
high school tennis team how'd that go
very poorly no I wasn't in high school
was my middle school tennis team I lost
three games or whatever you're like no
it's Game three Game three six yeah this
is a mode it's the best for we call it a
game lost three sets three six zero two
like 45 in each one she got you that
bagels she has a bunch of zeros yeah
whatever
really goes for it and they're really
for Natasha sake will you please like
comment and subscribe thanks for
watching see you next time I got kicked
out of my tennis camp
oh why are what being annoying
[Music]